hello and welcome everyone
my name is jan preschko i work on the
wolfram cloud team
and today i'm going to show you what's
new in our world and what we've been
working on
but first of all let me give you a quick
introduction to what the cloud is about
so the idea is that it brings the full
power of mathematica
and the wolfram language to the web so
that anybody can go to wolfencloud.com
sign up for a free account and start
working with notebooks
and write wolfram language code right in
a web browser
without installing any local software or
any browser plugin
it's also a way to share interactive
notebooks with others whether you create
them right in the cloud or
in desktop mathematica and upload them
later
and it's also a way to deploy arbitrary
web applications written
in the wolfram language to the cloud so
that other people can access them
so how does this look like it's
basically
the regular notebook interface that you
might be used to from desktop
mathematica
and actually right here this is a web
browser so it just happens to be
in slideshow mode that's why it's
looking a little different than usual
but this is interactive and editable as
usual you can
create text and sections and so on you
can also
write code and evaluate it of course so
this basically works there's support for
graphics
both two-dimensional and
three-dimensional in cloud notebooks
so you can do something like this and
then start interacting with the 3d
graphic in this case
and of course we have support for
manipulate which is a very important
and useful construct in the virtual
language so
if you do this you get the usual
manipulate interface where you can
drag around sliders and interact with
with the content and again this is all
running
in a web browser connected to a wolfram
cloud server
to get updates for this computation
whether you create notebooks in
desktop mathematica or on a cloud
eventually you might want to publish
them for us to look at them
and one convenient way to do that is to
use cloud publish
so if we want to take the manipulate
from before and
publish it to the web we can just say
cloud publish and then give it a name
and that will return a cloud object
cloud object is really just a reference
to a file in the wolfram cloud
in this case it's in my account with the
given name
and if i open that it opens this in a
so-called deployed view where i can
again interact with it
just one thing to keep in mind is that
there's different views of cloud objects
or different url types
most of the time you'll want to share
the so-called object view
denoted by this obj in the url with
other people because that's what's
publicly available if you set the
permissions accordingly
so yeah that's that's what you usually
use to share notebooks with other people
but sometimes it's useful to share url
that allows editing of the notebook
and that's what the the so-called
environment view is about
you can construct a url of that type
with the cloud object option cloud
object url type
and if i click this link now it opens
in this environment view where i can
also
edit this and you know have a file menu
and just more things i can do to work
with this notebook
something we just added recently is
download url type
which is a convenient way to hand out
the url that immediately triggers a
download
of the notebook so if i click this or
just
download the notebook to my local file
system
so that's just a general overview of how
notebooks work in the cloud there's also
other things so like
forms here we're publishing a so-called
form function
that takes a website name
as a parameter and then immediately
redirects
to that website so i can type something
like wikipedia
and it will go to wikipedia.org
you can see here let's try something
else so this is
a very simplistic search engine
implemented in a few lines of language
code
and of course you can add many more
fields
of different types and make use of a lot
of the
natural language understanding built
into the wolfram language
to to deal with forms
if your audience are not humans directly
but more like other programs
there is a way to deploy apis to the
cloud through a construct called aki
function
it works pretty similarly to form
function
just that it's not not meant for
human consumption but usually to be
called by
by other programs so the input will
usually be
some json payload and then you get back
another json data structure
in this case we're deploying
a very useful api that tells us whether
the year 2020 is finally over yet but
unfortunately
the answer is no still not there yet 88
days remaining so still gotta hang in
there for a while
um we can't change that but
we can cheat a little bit and in this
case pass in a different
date and on january 1st 2021
it will finally be there um
again this has the full power of
the natural language understanding of
the world from language building so i
can also
pass in things like yesterday here and
it will
interpret it as the right date and give
the right result obviously
so that's a few of the things you can
deploy to the cloud
just a few more notes about how cloud
objects work in general
we've seen this function cloud publish
which is essentially just cloud deploy
with public permissions and a few other
tweaks but they're more or less
equivalent
there's many other functions to manage
content in the cloud like copy file
which works both to and from a cloud
object handle
you can use cloud export to
export stuff to the cloud there's a
function cloud objects
to enumerate cloud objects in your cloud
account
and many more there's a whole guide page
in the documentation
that lists various functions that you
can take a look at
right so that's it in terms of cloud
objects now i want to talk about a few
of the things we've been working on
recently
one thing that just came to the cloud
over the last year
is rule from alpha notebook edition
which
basically combines the simplicity of
wolfram alpha
with the whole power of mathematica and
what you can do in the world from
language
there is a whole separate product that
you can subscribe to separately
to get access to go from alpha notebooks
but it's also available from most of our
other products
and in this case i can just go to the
file menu and say new
rule from alpha mode notebook and it
will create
this type of notebook where instead of
typical input cells where i type code i
can now type in
from alpha queries in natural english
language
so i type in what
city am i in and press
enter i will
get the result eventually so i'm in
vienna right now
i can keep exploring that result through
the suggestions bar which is
particularly handy
for notebooks like this you could ask
for the population or
where it is i could also
make another query and ask what's the
population of vienna over time
and notice that it also gives me
a corresponding rule from language input
in this case
it makes use of entities in the language
and then a time series as the result if
you want to look at that i could just
say
offstat and
what's what you can see here what's
really useful about rule from alpha
notebooks
is that they have some state in them so
you can refer
to the previous cell using that
and it will understand that you know i
want to plot the previous result
so i think this is a very useful way to
get familiar with the wolfram language
even if you're not used to programming
yet
you can just type regular english
language and get back results and at the
same time also see
what the corresponding wolfram language
commands would be
and learn the language slowly that way
so yeah it's nice that we have full from
alpha notebook edition on the cloud now
but new features aside the priority for
us recently has certainly been
improving robustness and performance of
the cloud
and one area that
i want to highlight in particular is
improved kernel isolation
we're now able to use a fresh new kernel
process
for each invocation of an api function
or other deployed objects in the cloud
we used to be not able to do that
because it was just too costly to start
a new
kernel process for each http request
but we're now using process forking at
the system level
to basically get a fresh process
in a pretty cheap way and
that's mostly invisible to users
but under the hood it's it's a big boost
for robustness of the whole system
and also if you're running a private
cloud you might be interested
in enabling this continuing in terms of
performance and robustness just on the
other end of the stack
is our project for client-side graphics
rendering
for most graphics what we still need to
do is
generate some extra data on the server
side so that the client can
turn it into svg graphics but what we're
increasingly trying to do
is render graphics purely on the client
side in our javascript code
this started with basically rendering
disk and circle boxes
and simple rgb colors but we're
constantly adding
more graphics directives and other
graphics features
to this client-side implementation
so what this allows us to do is to
render certain graphics
purely on the client side without the
extra complication and overhead of going
back to the server
for extra data and in combination with
a client-side evaluator that we have
that can evaluate simple workflow
language expressions purely on the
client side
we can create some pretty cool stuff
like this
animation here of of planets
that is running purely on the client
side without
needing any kernel but it's actually
implemented
in pure wolfram language
and yeah as we as we progress and add
more and more features to this
client-side graphics implementation
this will just be more powerful
another project in the area of graphics
is what we call interactive graphics
where the idea is that for certain plots
and
other graphics we add various
interactive effects
to make them nicer to look at and to
work with
so here we have a plot with points and
the lines and
what we might do is highlight the
nearest point
and also add drop lines so that you can
easily see
what the corresponding point on the axis
is
and this is the combined effort
between annotations added by the kernel
to the graphics box itself and
corresponding implementation on the
cloud side
so some of this is hopefully making it
into 12
2 and then we'll work in the cloud
and morris is probably coming later
including
exposing some lower level mechanisms to
users to also add
their their annotations and effects if
they wanted to
so there's a lot going on in terms of
graphics rendering in the cloud
but even more generally than that we're
always trying to
improve notebook performance in the
cloud
and particularly loading speed of
notebooks
one thing we've had for a while is
server-side rendering of notebooks
that generate some static html on the
server so that the page can load faster
and you see something pretty much right
away well
stuff still renders interactively in the
background
and and then everything is interactive
but
especially for very large notebooks that
could still
take quite a long time and it was kind
of distracting
to see the the notebook taking
a long time to become interactive so
what we've just been working on recently
is
to hook up even faster
static rendering mode and give you an
idea of that
let me show you a notebook how it might
have looked like before
if you load it in the cloud so this is a
pretty large notebook
and you can see it it takes a while
until anything shows up there's the blue
progress bar at the top
and then it it slowly makes its way
through
until it has it has finally rendered
all the cells on the client side and
for such a large notebook there isn't a
whole lot we can do
to to actually speed up uh
you know the rendering of each
individual cell much more
it just takes some time to do that in a
browser
but what we can do is it's trying to
avoid that live rendering
on the client side altogether and just
keep using
the static rendering that you already
have from the server
to to show the notebook and only start
the live rendering
once it's actually necessary and
that's exactly what this so-called
static rendering
method is about so on
this new branch that we have with this
new implementation
here's how this would look like first of
all
you can see the the static html cache
uh coming in right away and then it's
just much much faster
to to render the whole notebook
and now i can already scroll through it
might take a little bit
for each uh sort of section of the
notebook to render that's just the way
the browser works but it's it's pretty
smooth and i can just
scroll through it read the whole
notebook and in this case there isn't
even much missing
even though it's it's still using the
static rendering from the server
there isn't a whole lot of interactivity
in this notebook anyway
so some of the work that would have been
done
wouldn't really be necessary anyway for
other notebooks
that are more interactive here's what
will happen
so if in this case load a notebook
with the static rendering mode enabled
and
i have here manipulate so that really
wants to be interactive
even though we didn't render it
interactively right away
but then what happens is as soon as i
start interacting with that cell and
click here
it renders that one cell and makes it
interactive and i can just
keep dragging the slider and it
basically just works
the same let's say for for buttons you
can just press them and they they become
interactive
also graphics that you can resize and so
on so
it's it's still a pretty smooth
experience
but but just delaying a bunch of the
work that would happen
right away when you load the notebook
delaying that until later when it's
actually necessary
which makes for a much faster loading
speed especially for large notebooks
we'll probably enable this as sort of a
heuristic
for large notebooks beyond a certain
size
but there's also the cloud rendering
method option
that you can use to control this
explicitly
and this is coming in cloud 157 so in
the in the
upcoming cloud release
the goal with all of this is to be able
to use cloud notebooks everywhere
and to publish any content you like to
the cloud
but also to embed notebooks in other
websites that you might have
and one thing that particularly helps
with this is the wolfram notebook and
better
library that we released last year and
are continuously
improving as well so this is a
javascript library
that you can feed any url of a public
cloud notebook
and it will embed that notebook in
any other page some example applications
that already make use of this is for
instance
wolfram community which is very nice so
that you can
just integrate notebooks into community
posts
there's also the notebook archive coming
up with
tons and tons of notebooks based on the
cloud
and then there's also for instance the
github from document viewer
that allows you to take any repository
on github that might contain notebooks
and view them in the cloud so that's
just a few examples
and there's certainly many more use
cases
for for notebooks so these are a few
things we've been working on recently of
course there's
much more going on in addition to that
for instance we're working on
performance improvements
in terms of using the wolfram language
compiler to generate web assembly
that can be executed on the client side
without needing a kernel
we're also working on a new
implementation of cloud expression
which is a convenient way to persist
expressions in the cloud
we're starting to work on accessibility
and improving the way cloud notebooks
interoperate with screen readers for
instance
there's also a big project to move the
cloud to containers and kubernetes
which i think will be particularly
interesting for private clouds
and scaling them and having a more
redundant architecture there
and there is also still the big project
of implementing a full type setting
editor
in cloud notebooks what we have so far
is
basically just a one-dimensional code
editor and of course there can be type
setting
in the output but it's not editable yet
and that there will be a longer term
project to make that work
if you want to know all the details of
what's going on
you can take a look at our release notes
with every cloud release we also
publish a notebook that gives all the
details what happened in that release
i'm also happy that we finally have a
fairly accurate and complete list
of supported and unsupported wolfram
language functions
in the cloud so you can take a look at
that document
to see what's expected to work and
what's not expected to work yet
in the cloud and if you want to know
more details about cloud notebooks in
particular
you can take a look at these uh
implementation notes
that have a lot of detail about
various aspects of cloud notebooks you
want to get in touch please don't
hesitate to
shoot me an email or get in touch on
wolfram community
i'm always uh looking forward to
learning more about
what you do with the cloud so yep that's
it for my site
and thanks for listening